good morning hi it's Tuesday so I have
some important news about the movie
adaptation of my book Turtles all the
way down but first for context I thought
I would explain to you the Practical
parts of how a book becomes a movie and
the financial implications for an author
so first there is a book and in the case
of turtles the day after the book came
out a movie studio made an offer to
option that book into a movie which
means they have the option to develop it
into a film for I don't know say 24
months and most books that get optioned
do do not become movies like like my
book in abundance of Catherine's was
optioned and never became a movie Paper
Towns was optioned three times before it
became a movie but from an author's
perspective it's still nice because you
know you get a little bit of money and
you don't have to do any extra work for
it- which is kind of the American dream
so right now the studio has the right to
develop your work into a movie and they
hire screenwriters who write a
screenplay and generally that's where
things break down the script isn't good
enough or they can't attract the right
director or they hire the author to
write the script and it turns out the
author is a terrible screenwriter or
whatever but then sometimes they get a
good director and then it falls apart
because they can't settle on a cast or a
budget or whatever and occasionally
everything comes together they hire a
director they settle on a cast they
start hiring crew they're 12 days away
from shooting when a movie executive
decides I think I'm going to pull this
movie because I don't want to make it
because I feel like one of the cast
members just looks kind of weird like
kind of unsettling that's literally what
he told me and if any of that happens
the only money the author gets is the
option money like if the faar stars had
not turned into a movie I think I would
have gotten paid $660,000 which is a lot
of money to be clear but it's not like
Hollywood fantasy money so that's how
the vast majority of these deals work
you try to make a movie you work really
hard it just for whatever reason doesn't
happen but then occasionally of course
it does happen you get the right script
and the right director and the right
cast and crew and awesome movie
Executives who do exist by the way and
they make a movie and and that that
moment when they commence principal
photography that is the phrase they use
is the moment when authors get paid the
option is exercised and you get paid
generally several times the amount of
that option and that for authors
financially is usually it like unless
you're wildly famous you don't get a cut
of the box office so your last paycheck
from the movie comes with the
commencement of principal Photography in
that sense from an author's perspective
it doesn't really matter if the movie
comes out because you know you get paid
the same except of course it does matter
it matters a great deal when I started
the movie Journey with turtles all the
way down I had no idea how much I would
love the script which was written by the
lovely people who wrote Love Simon I had
no idea how much I would care about the
cast and the crew and our awesome
director Hannah Marks how much work they
would put into it and we would put into
it together I had no idea how much I
would end up loving loving the movie
which I just just think is truly truly
brilliant it's about socioeconomic class
and friendship and Free Will and of
course it's also about mental illness
and it manages to be raw and honest
without ever feeling sensationalized now
I don't think it would be accurate to
say I have no Financial incentive in the
movie's success because a successful
movie sells a lot of books and I I do
make money from Book Sales right it does
vary a lot based on how people respond
to the movie and also like whether they
know it's an adaptation of a book like
you know the movie Die Hard that's an
adaptation of a book and it hasn't like
become an American classic or anything
it's not like people read that book
every Christmas and I've been on both
sides of that equation like the Looking
for Alaska show was brilliant but it
didn't sell a lot of books the fult and
Our Stars movie sold a ton of books but
anyway even after you've cleared all the
other hurdles and the movie is made
there is still one more hurdle
increasingly movie studios just don't
release movies even movies that they've
already made and paid for this is aack
strategy as I understand it if they
believe the movie will lose more money
than just not releasing it and calling
it a total loss then they'll take that
tax right off instead of releasing the
movie now I'm biased obviously but I
think Turtles all the way down is a
great movie it's scored really well with
test audiences all that stuff but I am
conscious of the fact that it doesn't
have like superheroes and it isn't like
the seventh sequel in a popular
franchise I mean it's a movie about Free
Will and mental illness called Turtles
all the way down so you know I I I
worried about that until recently that
is when I got a call saying that the
turtles all the way down movie is coming
out later this year on Max you'll get to
see it and I'm so excited for you to see
it not for financial reasons but because
it is a beautiful beautiful movie I know
some of y'all wanted like a big
theatrical release but in 2024 for this
kind of movie this is a massive win and
it's the right way to share the movie
one thing I don't know about yet is
international distribution but it will
be in lots of places around the world
and I'm just so happy and relieved and
excited for this to actually happen and
also since Hollywood isn't exactly
beating down the door for the rights to
the anthropos reviewed or my forthcoming
book about tuberculosis this may be the
last time I get to experience hundreds
of people coming together navigating all
those obstacles and finding a way to
make something wonderful together and
then get to share it with an audience so
yeah later this year streaming on Max
what a joy what a relief Hank I'll see
you on Friday